The last couple of exercises, we've been looking at one
particular region of the ABO gene and the various alleles
that we can find there in the human population. But
here's a different region of the gene. So we're much earlier
in the genetic code here. We're still in the coding
region. But here we're looking from position 250 to position
270. And what I've done is I've underlined the genetic
code where in-frame here reading our codons in the DNA sequence.
And you see we've got one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven codons to read from. So now I want
us to do the same thing that we did in
one of the previous exercises. Imagine you're a ribosome, and you're
not reading the DNA. Remember, you've got to be transcribed
from DNA to RNA, and then RNA is translated by
ribosomes into protein. But these are the representative coding region
sequences. These are the DNA sequences that will eventually become the
codons, which are underlined here. And let's say that
we have two variations. And these times the variations
aren't a change in the letter, it's actually a
deletion of a letter or multiple letters. In this first
variant, we actually move along and then we delete
three letters in a row. In the second variation,
we actually delete only one letter. Tell me, which
one do you think will have a more significant effect?
The deletion of three letters or the deletion of
only one? Select one of these answers. And when you
do, I want you to think about why that
is and enter it into this text box here. Really
think about this one. Don't just answer it. Don't
just pick one. I want you to think about it.
Have a reason reason for it. Then select an
answer and tell me why in this text box here.